es ist etwas Grauenhaftes passiert etwas
womit man natürlich in diesem Ort
überhaupt nicht gerechnet hätte jetzt um
10 Uhr wird eine Pressekonferenz sein da
erhofft man sich natürlich weitere
Informationen zu diesem schrecklichen
Fall in Norwegen es gibt so sagt auch
wilde viele offene Fragen zu diesem
Zeitpunkt vor allem auch zum möglichen
Motiv und zum Hintergrund des Täters
wilder how do you think how will stay
will develop today what you expect from
the press conference do you expert that
a this time the will be any news
concerning 37 your old man who did this
[Musik]
ich habe die Kollegin aus Norwegen
gerade gefragt welche Erwartungen sie an
diese Pressekonferenz hat ab wann wohl
etwas mehr zum Hintergrund des Täters
erfahren wird und sie sagte ja es gibt
viele offene Fragen die wir beantwortet
haben wollen beispielsweise gab es
vorher auch schon Kontakt in irgendeiner
Form zur Polizei also war der Täter
Polizei bekannt das möchte man gerne
beantwortet haben und natürlich auch zum
Motiv gibt es viele offene Fragen will
der chose of the weapon was something
that shock surprised everybody you have
any explanation for that
no is so early to say that we know that
to use the several weapon sexually dass
diese
ich habe gerade noch mal gefragt der
Täter ging mit Pfeil und Bogen vor eine
sehr ungewöhnliche Wahl der Waffe ob es
in Norwegen derzeit irgendwelche
Erkenntnisse dazu gibt gibt es bisher
nicht man weiß aber mittlerweile er
hatte mehrere Waffen bei sich auch dazu
erhofft man sich natürlich auch
Antworten auf der Pressekonferenz will
der thank you very much for your time
thank you for your information and all
good thought to your country
und hier nach diesen ersten Stimmen
direkt von vor Ort aus Norwegen aus
Kongsberg und aus der Hauptstadt Oslo
von unserer journalistenkollegin wollen
wir hier im Studio weitersprechen über
diesen ja sehr bewegenden dramatischen
Fall dort aus Kongsberg und das tun wir
mit den Sicherheitsexperten malte
roschinski der zu uns gekommen ist heute
früh weil eben die Wahl der Waffe ja so
speziell ist in diesem Fall einen guten
morgen an sie und dann unseren Kollegen
Peter hell der im Fall an der spreeweg
ganz besonders recherchiert hat eine
Dokumentation darüber auch verfasst hat
mit unserer Kollegin Annika rasch
gemeinsam wie oft ist dir dieser Name
Brei Weg in den vergangenen Stunden
immer wieder in den Kopf gekommen
ja leider eigentlich fortlaufend die
Bilder die wir jetzt gesehen haben haben
einen erschreckenden Charakter gleichen
Charakter wie vor zehn Jahren dieser
dramatische schreckliche Amoklauf durch
Anders Breivik was vor zehn Wochen eben
sich auch zum 10 mal geehrt hat und vom
emotionalen her muss ich sagen
denkt man sofort an an dieselbe tat man
denkt oh Gott was ist da schon wieder
passiert warum wieder Norwegen warum
wieder wahllos Menschen irgendwo
ermordet worden das hat sehr starke
Parallelen
dann genau auf diesem auf diesen
Informationen muss man natürlich auch
gucken wie ist die Motivlage des Täters
wie ist er vorgegangen das wird die
Polizei natürlich jetzt alles prüfen
aber es hat sehr viel Ähnlichkeiten auch
dieses gezielte bei der Motivlage wie
gesagt wissen wir im aktuellen Fall noch
nichts wir können da noch keine parallel
ihn aber möglicherweise bei der Reaktion
der Polizei auch bei der Reaktion der
Sicherheitsbehörden wenn sie einmal und
auch du Peter einmal schaut wie lief das
da gestern vor Ort du weißt von
Spezialeinsatzkräften dort in Norwegen
kennst dich mit der Polizei Taktik dort
aus wie lief das gestern in den Minuten
nachdem die erste Alarmmeldung
eingegangen ist auch auf Erfahrung
dieses Falls brevik
das ist natürlich sehr schwer zu sagen
was kann man von hier aus nicht sagen
weil diese Kleinstadt wir haben es ja
gehört da ist die Polizeistation gerade
mal ein Kilometer entfernt und 30
Minuten scheint sehr lange zu sein im
üblichen ist die Polizei das muss man
auch sagen gar nicht bewaffnet in
Norwegen jetzt ist direkt danach auch
eine landesweite Anweisung gekommen
vom Innenministerium alle Polizisten zu
bewaffen landesweit eben um eventuell
Nachahmungstäter sofort stellen zu
können die Alarmkette die dort eintrifft
das kann man nur spekulieren warum es so
ist warum es so lange gedauert hat es
müssen natürlich bei solchen Sachen
direkt auch Spezialeinheiten zugezogen
werden und die delta-einheiten das ist
so eine Art Entschuldigung GSG9 wie bei
uns in Deutschland die sind in Ostsee
stationiert also eine Top trainierte
Elite einer die eben auf Geiselnahmen
terrorlagen trainiert ist die brauchen
auch natürlich etwas also ich gehe mal
davon aus dass es eine relativ
unübersichtliche Lage da ist dann
gewesen ist
dass man auch erstmal wissen muss wie
viel Täter sind es wer ist das und da
die Tat sich auch in mehreren Stellen in
dieser kleinen Stadt abgespielt hat geht
man natürlich erstmal von einer Großlage
aus dass es mehrere Täter sein können
also das dauert bis da zugegriffen
werden kann
überraschend wir haben darüber auch
gesprochen die Wahl der Waffe sehr sehr
ungewöhnlich Herr Roschinsky haben sie
eine Einschätzung dazu was das über den
Täter Aussagen könnte nun die Bedienung
von Pfeil und Bogen als als Waffe
erfordert schon Geschick und erfordert
Training das heißt hier liegt es nah
dass der Täter eine persönliche
Beziehung irgendwie dazu hatte das heißt
dass er vielleicht den diesen diesen
Sport betrieben hat dass er in
irgendeiner Weise
ausgebildet war oder trainiert war das
zu bedienen so einfach ist das nicht
also nicht jeder Anfänger kann sich fein
und Bogen aus dem Geschäft greifen und
dann einfach mal gezielt auch wirklich
drauf los schießen dazu braucht es eine
gewisse Vorbereitung und deswegen liegt
das nahe dass da irgendeinen Hintergrund
eben war das wird sicherlich jetzt auch
die die Ermittlungen zeigen ob das in
irgendeiner Form eine paramilitärischer
Ansatz war oder einfach ein sportlicher
Ansatz wir haben diese Pfeile gesehen
metallpfeile die dort ja auch in der
Wand stecken geblieben sind das zeigt
mit welcher Wucht diese Pfeile
geschossen werden bzw welche
Geschwindigkeit und welche Wucht die
auch entfalten braucht es dafür
eigentlich ein Waffenschein nein also in
Deutschland zum Beispiel ist so ein
Pfeil und Bogen sind Waffen natürlich
aber peinlich unter das das Waffenrecht
das heißt also ist ein erlaubnisfreie
waffenähnlich denke ich mal wird auch in
Norwegen sein aber es ist natürlich eine
gefährliche Waffe also beim beim
sportlichen bogenschießen ist so die
Geschwindigkeit die
abschussgeschwindigkeit von einem Pfeil
bei 100 Meter die Sekunde das ist schon
ganz ordentlich das ist nicht so viel
wie eine Pistolenkugel die ist etwa
dreimal so schnell eine Gewehrkugel ist
acht bis neunmal so schnell aber das ist
natürlich schon wenn man sich überlegt
100 Meter in einer Sekunde und die
Kinetik die dahinter steckt ist ja auch
beachtlich und man kann mit modernen
Bögen auch ziemlich präzise Zielen mit
den Recurve Recurve Bögen da gibt es
Zielvorrichtungen dran Stabilisatoren
etc da kann man dann schon welche
Entfernung etwa man kann da auf 30 50 70
Meter treffen es gibt Disziplinen da
geht es um 80 90 Meter aber im Grunde
kann man natürlich da entsprechend auf
einige Distanz dann auch Personen oder
Ziele insgesamt treffen man braucht dann
natürlich ein bisschen Ruhe für das
heißt das ist ja eigentlich das sind
diese Pfeile wenn ich noch mal ganz kurz
dazwischen gehen darf ja maschinski die
wie gesagt da in der Hauswand stecken
geblieben sind nach dieser schrecklichen
Blut wenn die damit 100 Meter die
Sekunde also gut 300 Stundenkilometern
ankommen das allein bringt ja eine
gewisse Knete mit sich und sie sehen ja
daran wie die da in der Hauswand stecken
bleiben wie das auch in anderen Zielen
passieren kann sie sagten auch gerade
dafür braucht man ein bisschen Ruhe
bisschen Zeit natürlich ist so eine
Waffe nicht so schnell bedienbar wie
eine schussfeuerwaffe beispielsweise
also man braucht dafür ja was können Sie
irgendetwas sagen was das darüber auch
über die Fertigkeiten dieses Täters
aussagt ist es eigentlich fast
auszuschließen dass derjenige nicht
irgendwie in einer Form darauf trainiert
war würde einem Laien das überhaupt
gelingen wir wissen nicht auf welche
Distanz was passiert ist ja wenn jetzt
der Täter die kennen die Umstände noch
nicht da werden wir jetzt ja in einer
Stunde hoffentlich ein bisschen mehr
erfahren oder auch in den nächsten Tagen
wird er immer mehr rauskommen es kann
natürlich sein dass er in einer
bestimmten Situation auf eine sehr kurze
Distanz da einfach aus irgendeiner
Tasche diesen Bogen gezogen hat und dann
überraschend weil natürlich niemand mit
so einer Art von Waffe auch rechnet
schon gar nicht in dieser Kleinstadt
dann in kurzer Zeit in einem begrenzten
Raum zum Beispiel ist die Rede war von
einem Supermarkt
falls man weiß ja was drin oder davor
aber in einem Supermarkt haben wir
natürlich noch viel kürzere Distanzen da
gibt es vielleicht die Möglichkeit auch
Menschen in die in eine enge zu drängen
und dann entsprechend halt zu Ziel
und dann mit einem
einschüchterungsverhalten die Leute auch
in einem Ort zu belassen und dann halt
innerhalb von 10 20 30 Sekunden zwei
drei Pfeile oder so abzuschießen soll
sich tatsächlich auch in diesem Koop
Supermarkt dort in dieser kleinen Stadt
Kongsberg abgespielt haben augenzeugen
haben am gestrigen Abend noch davon
berichtet dass der Menschen rausgelaufen
sein mit Pfeilen tatsächlich im Rücken
stecken Peter hell wir haben gerade die
aktuelle Nachrichtenlage noch mal
geschildert hier werden unsere Sendung
ist die Nachricht reingekommen dass der
Täter gestanden hat mittlerweile was
weißt du wenn du unseren Zuschauern noch
mal ganz kurz zusammenfassen kannst
aktuell über diesen Mann also wir wissen
dass sie sich um ein 37-jährigen Mann
aus Dänemark handeln soll
Staatsangehörigkeit dänisch was wir auch
gehört haben ist dass er sich wohl
ergeben hat dass er wohl noch eine
weitere Waffe bei sich getragen haben
soll nach unseren Informationen soll es
sich dabei um Messer gehandelt haben die
Polizei soll ein Warnschuss abgegeben
haben daraufhin muss er sich oder soll
er sich wohl ergeben haben also das
alles
deutet darauf hin dass solche Menschen
die in so einer amoxsituation sind das
alles sehr geplant haben und haben mit
auch rechnen dass sie festgenommen
werden was ich jetzt abspielt in der
Polizei oder abgespielt hat gestern
Abend ist extrem wichtig für die für die
Behörden weil nach wie vor zählt wie ist
die Lage gibt es mehrere Täter ist wie
Tat geplant hat so ein Täter eventuell
das kann man Abgleich mit Breivik
eventuell noch Sprengsätze irgendwo hin
steckt wie ist die Wahl der Opfer
vonstatten gegangen sind die gezielt
ausgesucht worden oder waren das
Zufallsopfer dann muss man sich
psychologisch auch in die Beamten muss
man erklären wie gehe ich an so ein
Täter ran das heißt
behandle ich ihn schroff versuche ich
ganz weil eben aus aufgrund der Notlage
herauszufinden weitere Informationen
oder versuche ich es sanft zu machen bei
Breivik haben sie es gemacht sehr sanft
weil sie wissen wollten sie wollten ihn
nicht verschrecken das hat vielleicht
hier aus stattgefunden also erstmal das
wichtigste ist erstmal die Erstaufnahme
dass ich weiß warum gibt es weitere
Täter gibt es ist die Gefahrenlage
gebannt also wir wissen dass das
Städtchen noch abgesperrt ist die suchen
noch nach weiteren Waffen etc also das
ist noch eine sehr
variable Situation
weitere schinski und unser Kollege Peter
hell vielen herzlichen Dank für ihren
für euren Besuch hier im Studio mit
neuesten Informationen zu dem
schrecklichen Fall in Kongsberg in
Norwegen wo ein Mann fünf Menschen mit
Pfeil und Bogen getötet hat und zwei
weitere Menschen zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
verletzt hat und es gibt jetzt auch neue
Erkenntnisse in dem Fall ja aktuell
hören wir zu all dem was Peter uns
gerade ganz aktuell geschildert hat dass
der Mann eine gewisse medizinische
Vorgeschichte haben soll also mehrfach
mit den norwegischen Gesundheitsbehörden
in Kontakt gewesen sein soll worum es
sich da gehandelt haben könnte ist
derzeit noch nicht bekannt er soll aber
auch polizeibekannt gewesen sein also
das sind die aktuellen Nachrichten die
jetzt so minütlich hier eintröpfeln auch
während unserer Sendung peter hat gerade
schon gesagt das wird eine
Pressekonferenz geben in rund 40 Minuten
dort in Norwegen im Süden Norwegen sind
Kongsberg in dieser Stadt die 80
Kilometer entfernt ist von Oslo und auf
diese Konferenz schauen wir natürlich
gleich und Sie hören von uns sobald es
dort neue Entwicklungen gibt nach dieser
schrecklichen Blut Tat vom gestrigen
frühen Abend gegen 18 Uhr 30 ist das ja
alles passiert dort in Kongsberg ein
Mann zieht mit Pfeil und Bogen durch
eine Kleinstadt und ermordet dort fünf
Menschen und verletzt mindestens zwei
weitere schwer
krank geschrieben
[Musik]